اجمعت المؤسسات الاقتصاديه الدوليه الكبرى
على تراجع معدل النمو الاقتصادي المصري
خلال العام الجاريه وذلك جراء مجموعه من
العوامل وفي مقدمتها تفاقم معدلات التضخم
وتهاوي سعر صرف الجنيه امام الدولار وهروب
مليارات الدولارات من البلاد
وتراجع الصادرات وتقلص القطاع الصناعي ففي
البدايه خفض صندوق النقد الدولي من
توقعاته لنمو الاقتصاد المصري خلال العام
المالي الحالي ثلاث مرات متتاليه حيث خفض
الصندوق معدل نمو الاقتصادي من خمسه في
المئه الى 44 اعشار في المئه
ثم سرعان ما خفض هذا النمو الى اربعه في
المئه فقط في اخر تقرير له وفي المقابل
خفض البنك الدولي توقعاته لنمو الاقتصاد
المصري الى اربعه ونصف في المئه كما توقع
البنك الاوروبي لاعاده الاعمار والتنميه
تراجع معدل نمو الاقتصاد المصري الى اربعه
وسته اعشار في المئه خلال العام الجاري
وذلك مقارنه بخمسه وسته اعشار في المئه في
تقريره السابق الذي اصدره في شهر ايلول
سبتمبر الماضي كما توقعت مؤسسه التصنيف
الائتماني فيتش تراجع معدل نمو الاقتصاد
المصري الى اربعه ونصف في المئه هذا العام
ياتي ذلك فيما هو سعر صرف الجنيه المصري
امام الدولار بحوالي 100% في الفتره من
شهر مارس اذار الماضي حتى شهر فبراير شباط
الفائت وجاء ذلك مع معدل التضخم السنوي في
المدن المصريه الى نحو 26% في شهر يناير
كانون الثاني الماضي وهو اعلى مستوى منذ
خمس سنوات وقد لجات مصر الى صندوق النقد
الدولي 4 مرات من اجل مساعدتها ماليا في
السنوات الست الماضيه
ولجات القاهره مرات كثيره الى دول الخليج
لانقاذها ماليا واقتصاديا لكن هذه الدول
الخليجيه بدات في وضع شروط اقتصاديه تنهي
عهدا من المرونه في الاستجابه للمطالب
الماليه المصريه
ولم يبقى امام مصر سوى بيع مزيد من الاصول
والشركات والبنوك العامه كي تخفف من عمق
ازمه البلاد الماليه التي لا يلوح في
الافق حتى الان بصيص املا لحلها